(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the "Addy Hour",
it's been my pleasure to
continue to engage with you on
these conversations.
And today I'm really excited
to welcome two special guests
to the program to talk about
a really important topic.
Our first guest is Stacey D. Stewart,
and Stacey is the president
and CEO of the March of Dimes,
where she has been in
that role since 2017.
And she heads the organization
that really is leading the
fight for the health of moms and babies.
Prior to joining the March of Dimes,
she was actually the
president of the United Way,
the nation's largest
nonprofit organization
and served in that role even
prior to being president in
that organization was also
the executive vice president
of community impact
leadership and learning,
where she developed global partnerships
to advance community impact
in more than 40 countries.
So definitely a person who
has had a lot of impact,
in a lot of ways.
She's had, she's a business veteran,
who's had a lot of different senior roles,
has a background in finance
and investment banking
and continues to serve on lots
of different national boards
and in the Washington
DC metropolitan area.
So I'm thrilled, excited,
and honored to welcome Stacey
Stewart to the program today.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here.
- Definitely looking
forward to the conversation.
Our next guest is Angelina Spicer.
Angelina is a comedian
social media influencer
and accidental activist.
A cum laude graduate of Howard,
Angelina is known for her
deep and authentic comedy.
She's had just outstanding
success has been her videos
and her content has been viewed
more than 90 million times
in more than 45 countries.
She was a regular sketch
performer on "Jimmy Kimmel Live"
and then "Conan" has
also appeared on "Ellen"
and "On The Real".
In 2017, Angelina also
became an outspoken advocate
for maternal mental health,
after her own diagnosis
and hospitalization with
postpartum depression.
But in addition to that,
she's also been working
with lawmakers in California
and on Capitol Hill to
implement laws to support
early maternal health,
has worked with lots of
different organizations,
including Cedars-Sinai hospital,
Postpartum Support International,
the World Health Organization, and others,
and is currently in production
on "The Push for Permission"
a feature length
documentary that uses comedy
to empower women, to
advocate for themselves
and to normalize postpartum depression.
So I'm grateful and
honored to welcome Angelina
to the program today as well.
Thanks for being here.
- Thank you for having me!
- Of course, my pleasure.
And as we talked offline
before I even started,
my goal today is to see if I
can keep up with the energy,
in the room, so to speak.
(all laughing)
I'm really excited and honored though.
But I've been really
looking forward to this
for several different reasons,
which I've alluded to already;
one, just because of the
impact and the influence
that both of you had, have as
a black women in our society.
I think that's so important,
it's so important for us to elevate
and to continue to amplify
and just the important topics
that you've both been talking about
and the impact you've
had policy-wise as well.
I think that's really impressive.
The other piece that I think
we'll get to as we go through
is just also your roles
as strong black women.
And we may be able to dive
into that conversation
and talk about the mixed
reactions to that term itself,
the pluses and the minuses
that come with that.
But I think it's important for
us to be able to acknowledge
that here as well.
But as my listeners know,
I always like to check in
and see how people are doing overall.
So with all the roles that you both have,
I imagine you have very busy schedules.
I just wanted to see
how you're doing today
and how you continue to balance
that on a day to day basis.
So Stacey, if we could start with you.
- Yeah, no, it's rare
that even someone asks
in a sort of a genuine,
authentic way, (chuckling)I mean
people always say, "How are you doing?"
And you just kind of say, "Great."
And it may not always be
great. So thank you for asking.
I'm doing, I actually am
doing pretty well today.
I'm a little tired from
watching some Olympics
and I, my bedtime gets pushed
back to earlier and earlier.
So if it's past 10 o'clock now,
I'm like I'm exhausted the
next day, which has got a bad,
but it's actually been great.
And I guess, it's interesting
that we're talking about
mental health things today.
Cause I think what's been
weighing heavily on my mind
with the Olympics, are
just incredible issues of
Simone Biles, and Naomi
Osaka, and Chicari,
and all of these black
women, who are stellar,
like world-class athletes.
And just the level of,
if they're feeling the
pressure of day-to-day life,
just imagine what the rest
of us normal people feel,
but just how interesting it is that
the theme of mental health
among black women athletes
is really showing up in a big way.
So anyway, I know that's
not exactly the topic,
but it is around mental health generally.
- Yeah.
- So I just,
that's actually been
ironically heavy on my mind,
but I'm doing great and
everything's good and it's summer.
So yeah it's hot,
but it's good.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Glad to hear that.
And I appreciate the
way that you're honest
in that comment, on
that, the answer as well,
and even some of the topic, I mean,
you're talking about paying
attention to your own sleep too.
So we are gonna have an episode coming up,
just talking about the importance of sleep
and how that intersects
with our mental health.
And it's great to hear that
you're attentive to that
in your own life.
And yeah, as you mentioned
with our black female athletes,
all the pieces that are
coming to light now,
which I think it's really important
for us to be able to talk about.
And in some ways,
we know those things have
been there for awhile,
but we haven't had the space
or the opportunity to really
shed light on it like we should.
So I think it's challenging
and a struggle for many,
but also an opportunity for
us to really be supportive
of these athletes and open
up the conversation much more
than it's been in the past.
So I appreciate you
bringing that in as well.
- Yeah.
- Angelina, what about you?
How are you doing.
- Well, I am currently on my
#postpartumrevolutionroadtrip.
It's my sort of missionary work,
to take post-partum
depression really on the road,
across the country, raising awareness
and shooting my documentary about
"Postpartum Depression,
Meeting With Lawmakers".
And this is my first
tour, both as a comedian,
- Oh, wow!
- as an entrepreneur.
And when you ask, how am I doing?
I'm doing very, very, very well.
I am so overwhelmed with purpose right now
and overwhelmed with the support
that it's being made very clear to me
that I am doing what I
was placed here to do.
- Wow!
- Hmm.
- And I'm just very
thankful for God's yes hand
of my request, and I've been on the road,
so I've been eating like
crazy and not sleeping well
and managing schedules
and panelists and shows
and everything, but today was
the first day that I took time
for myself to work out for
the first time since my tour.
- Wow!
- And I lived a little weight,
so I got my jump rope in and I feel great.
Thank you for asking.
- Of course.
And thanks for sharing that.
I mean, I think there's so much
in what you shared as well,
even in the last episode that we had,
we were talking about just
that aspect of purpose,
and how that impacts our mental health
and it sounds like a lot of ways.
Even though this is the first tour,
maybe not the first time
that you're in your purpose,
but it sounds like it's
a whole nother level
that everything is kind
of just tying in together,
- Yes.
- which I think is great.
So I think-
- It's all good.
- Yeah.
- It's so good.
- I'm sure it's fulfilling
and gratifying a lot of ways.
To follow up briefly though,
- Yes.
even with your answer, I'm curious,
because you mentioned all
the business of the tour too,
- Yes.
- so it's not that
what you're doing is stress free or easy.
So how are you staying in
that place where you're able
to answer and say, "I'm
doing really well,"
amidst all of the scheduling
and traveling and all...
Is that because of your
doing your purpose,
are there other things
that you have put in place
that are allowing that to happen?
I'm just, I'm curious.
- I'm a planner and plans, making plans,
executing that plans are
always sort of my checks
and balances on how I execute things.
So that helps my peace of mind going in,
if I know that I have a plan,
but because this is my first tour
and I'm traveling with a
crew of 10 camera people
and sound people, and we're
traveling in a 40 foot RV
across the country,
there's a lot of variables,
but because of the women that I'm meeting
in each of these cities
and because of the openness
that lawmakers have
to meet with me and the
yeses that I'm getting,
I'm taking chances, but
I'm getting yeses that meet
the risks, that feels
good, that's fueling me.
Cause I feel like,
"Okay, I'm taking a risk
and it's actually working.
- Yeah.
Okay. I guess we're doing
this. This is it. Okay."
So yes, it feels...
(laughing) That's how I'm managing.
- Yep. That's great.
Well, I mean, in a sense
too, you're getting that,
not to get too much into
my psychology neuroscience,
but that positive reinforcement
of taking that risk
and then seeing it come to fruition
and then being willing
to take that next risk
and then just having that feedback.
So I think that that's
outstanding in a lot of ways so-
- Thank you.
- And just to add a little bit,
how did the two of you
come into contact together?
I know you work together
in different ways,
but how did that story come about?
Whoever wants to-
- I ant Stacey
to answer this question.
(All laughing)
- I'm trying to think, how did we, I mean,
I think it was kind of
maybe through social media.
Well, first of all, I know Angelina,
you were connected with March
of Dimes out in LA anyway,
and then I was it there just
to kind of through social media
and connecting, and then we
got you involved in some stuff
and you were involved with March for Moms,
which is another organization
and we're connected to them too.
And then, what was it?
It was pre pandemic.
So we had dinner together
and we talked about like
how we could do more together.
I just think in some of
these spaces where a lot of
maternal health people are
kind of coming together,
especially around black, maternal health,
we're all meeting new people
and connecting with people
and forming alliances and
partnerships, and we were,
when Angelina first started talking about
the postpartum revolution,
and like this whole effort
to get this comedy special going,
I don't think a lot of
people really believed in it
or felt like it was really important.
And she really stayed on with this vision.
I think I chipped in some
money personally, very small.
And then it's led to us kind
of being in partnership with
her on this whole tour
thing and being a...
So anyway, it just, I think
there just a lot of, I mean,
that's how it should really
develop is that like you start
to meet people, expand, you grow
and she's been such a passionate sort of,
and a very interesting voice
in the space of maternal health
that it made a lot of sense
for us to figure out how
we could be more supportive of her work
and really partner so we can
reach more women for sure.
Yeah.
But is that right? Am I missing...
I'm missing something
aren't I, I don't know.
- Well, you're not Stacey.
I mean, I meet people on
social media all the time,
I don't always meet CEOs on social media.
So when I met a black woman
CEO, from March of Dimes,
I was like, "What? Let me find out."
So I wasn't gonna say it Stacey.
That's why I allowed you you'd
answer the question first
because I wasn't sure what
we were actually gonna say.
But, yes, Stacey and I
met on social media and I-
- She slid in my Dms, but not in...
In a good way.
(all laughing)
I admit I did slide in Stacey's Dms
and I was so honored that she replied
and that I felt a connection.
And I came to the March for Moms
and I usually participate every year
and speak at their rally
on the National Mall
and participate in their advocacy day.
But Stacey was like, "We
have to go to dinner.
I want to take you to dinner."
We had dinner and we put on
lipstick, we took our selfies.
And I was just like, I felt so connected,
but also left feeling like
I want to be in partnership
with March of Dimes because of Stacey.
So I've been ringing the
bells and advocating.
I mean, even when we're not
technically in partnership,
like we are right now in the
#postpartumrevolutionroadtrip,
I make sure at all of my events,
I have March of Dimes
resources for my moms
and for folks that come to my events,
but aren't even expecting
to be lectured about
postpartum depression, I'm like, "Hold on,
here, take a March of Dimes pamphlet.
Here's some resources for you."
I make sure that I lean into
the work that they're doing
with all of my events and
all of my work that I do.
- Yeah. Well, that's great.
- She's amazing.
- I think that speaks to both,
the authenticity that both of you have,
just in your interactions with each other
and just how you come across,
it seems like you really fired off of that
when you first interacted to first met
and have that common cause too.
So it's really exciting to hear, I mean,
all the important work that you're doing,
you both alluded to some
of the pushback though,
that you got early on and I would,
or people not believing in the mission.
I'm just curious if you could
elaborate on why that is,
especially in this day and age,
when there seems to be
more conversation now,
but there's always still that pushback.
- Yeah.
- Where do you think
that's coming from?
- Well, I'll start Angelina, I think...
So there's pushback at a
number of different things.
I mean, I think first
of all, in the country,
we weren't even having
these conversations around
maternal health, generally,
physical, mental, any kind of, women,
because I think a lot of it is
that women generally are not
prioritized in this country
the way we should be.
And then certainly pregnant women are not,
it's appalling though that
in a society like ours,
we wouldn't be putting as much priority on
the lives of moms and babies.
I mean, it's just striking.
And we, obviously we talked
a lot about the fact that,
we are considered the most
dangerous developed nation in
the world in which to give birth now,
how in the U S do we find
that at any acceptable, right?
And so I think it's just been, I honestly,
I think what's happening
is that the storytelling is
beginning to breakthrough. I mean,
Angelina telling her a story,
Beyonce telling her stories,
Serena telling her story,
or someone like Charles
Johnson telling his story,
about Kira who died, in a hospital in LA.
Once those stories...
Storytelling we know is very powerful.
So March of Dimes can be
ringing the bell all day.
And we have been talking
about premature birth
for a long time, but when those acts,
when those stories
started to break through,
it changes the whole narrative,
it changes the public awareness
in sort of embeds itself
in everyday conversation
and people's consciousness in a way that
organizations like mine can't always do.
And so, now we've gotten to
the point where, I don't,
I still don't think we're
paying enough attention to it,
prioritizing it in a way that it
should be in dealing with it
with the sense of urgency.
But I definitely can say that we're at
a different level of
conversation about it,
and a lot of different
level of attentiveness.
And I'm saying that from the
respect of Washington DC,
where I think policy makers are trying to
are starting to look at
this very differently.
So it just takes time.
These things don't always
happen overnight, but we're,
we certainly have made a lot
of progress in my short time
here at the March of Dimes
which is 4 1/2 years.
Then Angelina, what do you think?
- I realized that I have
a unique voice, in that,
I am yes a storyteller, but
I'm also a volatile comedian.
Okay and so that's where
the pushback for me came,
with people particularly organizations,
not in the comedic world.
I mean, I've gotten pushed back
on both sides, both in the,
on the organizational side and
on the Hollywood side. Okay.
So on, and I say, organizational,
I mean like non-profits,
policies, hospitals, brands, et cetera,
On that side, there's
pushback or hesitancy
because I am a comedian and I
can say whatever it is I want.
And usually comics go
off the rails sometimes,
they can go off the rails and
say crazy things, et cetera.
So I'm a liability.
I can be perceived as a
liability on that side.
For example, I have
been fundraising for my,
"The Push for Permission" documentary film
that I'm currently crowdsourcing
and, putting together
and producing and I went to a hospital
and we had an amazing pitch meeting.
We showed them all of our assets,
all of the production companies
and networks that are
interested in our film.
And they're like, "Well,
we don't know what you're gonna say."
So there was hesitancy from that.
And, I'm an artist first.
I don't wanna be censored,
but I also realize their
obligation to their board
and those that keep the
organization functioning.
So that's okay.
What troubles me the
most, I would say is that
Hollywood has pushed back in
a way that reinforces the idea
that you don't matter
unless you're a celebrity,
you don't matter because quote,
no one knows who you are.
And I've had a number
of production companies
and networks tell me, "Well,
why do we care that you
have postpartum depression?
We could ask Gwyneth
Paltrow. We could ask-"
- Basically Megan or somebody. Yeah.
- Exactly.
And regardless of my messaging,
my messaging is very
different, from a Beyonce,
definitely from a Gwyneth
Paltrow coz I'm sister
and I have a comedic voice, so
there's gonna be some levity.
There's gonna be humor.
There's gonna be
accessibility to my messaging.
But in Hollywood, it doesn't
matter because quote unquote,
no one knows who you are.
So I, that's why I have
just been so hyper-focused
on my small donors and knocking on doors
and I'm just going to make the film,
make the project that I
wanna see in the world.
That's not triggering, that
moms can see themselves in,
and I've gained partnerships
from organizations along
the way, Hollywood is slow
going, but it doesn't matter
because I know that there's
an audience for my work.
And I know that there's value in it,
whether or not I'm a celebrity.
- Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
I appreciate you sharing
that level of candor too.
Cause I mean, so speaking as
a complete Hollywood outsider,
just hearing you talk about
that just makes it sound like
that the, there isn't an
emphasis on the message.
- Never.
- Whatsoever.
- There's emphasis on
the money and I get it.
Listen, which is why I'm like,
"I will raise my own money to
get my own message out there."
Because I know that
there's an audience for it
and if its slow going,
whatever it is, we're doing it.
So, it's in motion, it's happening.
And moms are reaching out to
me in droves on social media
and organizations, the University
of Nairobi reached out.
I started working with WHO,
University of South Africa,
the Israeli government reached
out and wants me to come
and do trainings, and
with Doulas and Burke,
Hollywood is not the end ordeal.
My mission is bigger than the nose.
It's fully for the moms who are
in distress, the moms to be.
So I'm clear on my audience.
If Hollywood wants to be
late, let them be late.
That's all right.
- Yep. And the way you've
talked about that too,
it sounds like people are able to relate
and that might be an
advantage of the non Hollywood
route anyway, that people
can see you for who you are
not have to worry about stature
and not to say that
you're not accomplished,
but just say, "Okay, this
is someone I can relate to.
They've gone through it.
I can connect to them."
And I think there's just such
a power that comes with that.
- I agree.
And I joke and I say,
nobody knows who I am.
So people care more,
and I have less to lose.
So I can talk about, my broken lady parts
and how much I hated my husband
after I had my daughter,
because I'm not Serena Williams.
If Serena says that she has endorsements.
- She's gonna break the internet, right?
- That's right she's
gonna break the internet
and then that overshadows text capability-
- Yeah, the message, the message.
Yeah.
- Yes the message.
And me, nobody knows me, so
girl, you gonna get the whole,
prospect of my business
and that makes it better,
more accessible.
- But I also think that the...
So let's get to the message, right?
Which is that, I mean,
how many people really do want
to talk about mental health
in a really sincere way anyway?
How many people actually want
to hear about it in a way
that is not uncomfortable for them?
I mean, it's just, we have,
we are so incapable right now,
incapable of really
acknowledging the degree to which
we completely under fund, under resource,
the mental health challenges
that so many people in this country face.
I mean, we're talking about
women who are pregnant
or who give birth and who are new moms,
but frankly, I mean, what, where,
we wouldn't even have an opioid crisis
to the extent that we do,
if we didn't have a lot
of people struggling
with their mental health
and this is not new, right?
Like we've been dealing
with this for a long time.
And I think it's just
really something that
we are trying to get this message.
I mean, it's, so to the
question about pushback, I mean,
I think a big reason why we
do see the pushback is that
people are just really, really
struggling with even how
to acknowledge these
issues and talk about them
and then frankly deal with them.
And I do think that's why
it's so important that people,
even if Angelina is whatever
level of celebrity she wants
to call herself, she still
has a huge following.
She has a huge voice.
And I do think that it
makes a big difference
when people who are visible,
who are in the public side,
make themselves vulnerable
to talk about these things,
because it helps all of
us when I go to the hill,
if it helps me have a member of Congress,
has seen something on social media
or a movie or a documentary,
like then it makes it that
much easier when we had to say,
"Yeah, well, you know about that now,"
go ahead and give like however
many millions of dollars
(laughing) we need to
make sure that we have
a 24 hour mental health
hotline for new moms
or to make sure we have the resources
to make sure we have Medicaid coverage
for women who are seeking
those kinds of supports
and need their coverage paid for, right.
That it makes it that much easier.
So it's all of these individual efforts
that collectively roll
up to something where
we actually eventually have a movement
that actually moves the needle
and then it gets change to a
place where we can get help to
the people that really need it.
- Yeah, I think that's so all sad.
And I'm so, so glad that you're able
to harness the power of
all of those components,
even when you're on the hill.
Cause I mean, that
makes a huge difference.
And I wanted to pick
up on one of the things
that you mentioned too,
just in terms of us not
knowing how to really engage
and talk about it, because
even as you mentioned,
as I'm sure you all know the stats too.
I mean, even before
COVID, just thinking about
mental health challenges in
this country, one in five,
who are struggling with mental
health in some shape or form.
So when you break that down,
most of us, either personally,
ourselves or family members
or friends know somebody
who's struggling in some shape
or form with mental health,
but we still don't know how
to engage with it always.
And we still don't fully acknowledge it.
So I'm even thinking about,
as you're talking about on the hill,
I would imagine most of
the people in those rooms
are in some shape or form touched
by mental health challenges,
but does that mean that
we engage in it or not?
And so I'm curious as to
how, as an organization
and Angelina as you how
you've tried to address
that piece of it too,
because a lot of times it's
not far from where people
live in a metaphorical sense,
but in some ways it there's
this aspect of denial
and not engaging.
- Yes.
- Yeah. I I'll just, I
mean, one of the things,
I just think it's not only everyday people
and policy makers are not engaged.
We even have healthcare providers
that don't even know how
to ask these questions.
We have, one in five
women who are pregnant,
who never get asked for
screening for depression
like Angelina and even even
more that don't get asked,
during whether or not they're
having any kinds of signs
or symptoms of depression
in the postpartum phase.
When we look at maternal deaths overall,
about one in nine maternal
deaths are actually attributed to
issues around maternal health.
So these issues are really life and death.
And so part of what we've been saying is,
"We need to make sure
that everyone is aware
of where these issues show up.
We need to have everyone
prepared to see certain warning
signs or symptoms that could
help someone get referred to
help the health they need,"
but we have to have our own
healthcare professionals
and the health and hospitals
and healthcare providers
absolutely focused on this
and not willing to turn a blind
eye to anxiety and stress,
or just like chalking it up as, "Oh yeah.
Well, that's normal.
There's always a little
postpartum depression."
Well, why is, why should...
Even if that exists and
we do see it, what owners,
or what responsibility do you have as
a healthcare professional
to screen for it,
to refer women to the kinds
of support that they may need,
ask the question?
And what we're really saying is,
some of those healthcare professionals,
aren't even the OBGYN where
women may not be even going back
in for their followup visits
after the baby is born.
Sometimes it's the
pediatricians who need to be,
and we're really glad
pediatricians have this
on their radar screen increasingly.
So it could be screening
for during well-child visits
and things like that.
So it's really kind of raising awareness
and making it more of a ongoing
way of practicing medicine.
But knowing that our
health is not determined by
what happens in that
in the doctor's office,
mostly we have to have family
members, community members,
clergy, and others, willing
to talk about these issues
and help our fellow, especially new moms.
If they see, if they are showing signs
that they're struggling and
make it available for them
to acknowledge that they may be struggling
and then find that help.
I think Angelina's story
around that is really powerful
about, how she eventually got
to the help that she needed,
but thank God that she was
able to be in the hands of
a care provider who really
paid attention to her,
listened to her and found
her the care that she needed
and recognized it, that she
actually needed it because,
we wouldn't want to have seen
a worse outcome for Angelina
and or any other mother
as a result of just
giving birth to their child. Right.
I mean, it's, no woman should
have to struggle on that way.
- Yeah. It's so important,
needs to be elevated all
the way around, as you said,
society-wise, healthcare-wise,
and I love how you're tying
in all different aspects,
holistically clergy, community members,
all we need to be on
the same page together
to really make sure the
conversation doesn't get left.
Angelina I wonder if you'd
be able to share a little bit
about what you've learned
in your journey too,
and how that's informing the
work that you're doing now,
given as you're on tour.
- Which journey?
I'm on a lot of journeys.
- That's true.
The journey with you with your postpartum
after the birth of your new child.
- Oh my gosh. Well, I
feel like I should give
an abbreviated version of what happened.
- Because-
- Yeah, if you're willing.
That be great.
- No, I mean, I tell my
business for a living so
let's have at it.
Yeah. So I am married.
I like to tell people that
because they think that,
black women don't get
married, but I'm married.
I actually planned my daughter.
That's another stereo type of stigma.
So married, planned pregnancy,
educated, middle-class
and again, I'm a planner.
So I plan for this life,
but I didn't on developing
postpartum depression.
I had a doctor who I felt
like really minimized
my anxiety during my pregnancy.
And it was a developing anxiety
because I was marked high
risk towards the end.
And I didn't recognize it as
anxiety because I didn't know
what I was really experiencing in it.
And I didn't know that it had a name.
So, and there was so much preparation
for the birth of my daughter
that I wasn't really put.
I didn't feel like I was
put on the right track
to be prepared for once
she actually got here.
So when I pushed her out,
there's a picture of me
that's gonna be in the film
where I just looked afraid.
I look scared.
And that was the first
time they laid her on me.
It was the first time
I looked into her eyes
and I was overwhelmed by
my new responsibilities
as her provider and protector.
I just, I was scared.
And then, compound that
with the sleepless nights,
with the aching body
parts, the diapers, the,
my relationship with my husband was tested
like all relationships are,
after you have children.
I just felt like everyone lied to me.
I felt like my doctors
lied by not preparing me
for what was to come.
I felt like my friends, my peers,
no one was honest about what
their bodies had gone through.
I just felt like everyone
was kind of muscling through
and forgetting, forgetting to tell me.
So when I felt like I was having,
experiencing depressive
thoughts and intrusive thoughts,
which I didn't know was a thing,
now, luckily I was under the
care of a therapist for years.
I had seen my therapist before I,
like six years before I
decided to have my daughter.
And so she knew my baseline.
We had a very good relationship
and she was suggesting
things to me over the months
that I was literally
trying to climb myself out.
And one day at eight months postpartum,
I went to her office
and she recommended that
I check into a psychiatric facility.
And most people would be
afraid. I was excited to go.
I was relieved.
- I was-
- It was time.
It was time to feel better.
I wanted to feel better.
I just didn't know how.
And my therapist gave me
permission, to go to this place
and get, be taken care of.
And, all my meals were provided.
It was a great time out,
that I didn't know that
I could get as a new mom.
And then since then,
I've just really been advocating
for new moms, new families,
new parents, and even women
who are yet to become parents.
I feel like we need to
be honest with them about
what this is really gonna look like.
- Yep. Yep.
- Cause that ain't
what you think is gonna look like,
it's not gonna be horrible, it's not bad,
but it's not what you go,
what you think is gonna look like.
So, and to your former
point about the pandemic
and the stressors of the pandemic,
I know for myself, the
lockdown, the quarantine made me
and homeschooling made me feel triggered.
I felt extremely panicked and worried,
and I felt incapable, all over
again in capable of mothering
and in capable of balancing.
And my husband and I
decided after a few months
that it was time for us to send
our daughter back to daycare
because I just wasn't able to manage,
but that was the best decision
for our family at the time.
And I needed the freedom to
be able to say, "I'm drowning.
I can't do it."
But there were a lot of moms who felt,
the same symptoms of having
postpartum depression
- Yeah.
- during the pandemic.
- Yeah. There's a lot there.
And I appreciate you
sharing that story as well.
I mean, so many pieces that
you're paying it forward
and in a sense, too,
because even as you were
talking to your story,
talking about how you
didn't have the language
to know exactly what
you were going through,
even as someone who had
already been in therapy.
So I think that's a
really critical point too,
to make sure that people,
as you've already done
are having those
conversations ahead of time
and know what to expect
and how to move through it.
Because even as,
I mean, both sides are
working simultaneously,
even as you all are doing,
trying to make sure that
healthcare workers are providing
that information,
- Yes.
- having those who are going through it,
have that information as well.
And so when the misses still
happen to be able to tackle it
from both sides, in a sense,
I think is hugely important.
- I think-
- And then everything
you mentioned...
Oh, go ahead, Stacey.
- Well one thing I want to say about,
what Angelina said is that I
think that idea that when you,
so for a lot of, I mean,
I'll just speak to my own experience.
Cause it's, I mean,
I didn't go through the level
of postpartum depression
that Angelina experienced,
but I do think that there is something
about becoming a new mother
that is incredibly shocking.
And like, I don't think anyone is ever...
I can't imagine that anyone is, I mean,
if you're well-prepared for
motherhood, as soon as it hits,
like God bless you. Right?
Cause I think it is such an out-of-body,
like literally having an
out-of-body experience.
And it's...
I can remember feeling like the same thing
when Angelina said, which
is like, "They lied to me."
Because, everyone says, "Oh,
motherhood is so beautiful
and wonderful and you're gonna love it."
And honestly, the first few days,
weeks are so incredibly hard.
It is a hard...
And this is for someone like
me who didn't have to deal with
as many of the mental health challenges.
It didn't matter. It was
incredibly difficult.
And I was someone who had already, like,
I had my kids really late.
I mean, my first daughter
was born when I was 38.
And I, by then I'd been at the workplace,
work world and I had done all
these things in my career.
And so to be home for four
months at home, by myself,
with my child who cannot speak to me,
I could not have a cogent conversation
(all laughing)
with this little child,
- Yeah.
- and then, it was like,
I was like, I don't
think I'll survive this.
This is so hard.
So I think, and then of course,
all of your physiological
changes are complicating
how you process all this,
all the lack of sleep,
trying to eat healthy,
eat at all first of all.
(all laughing)
I mean, it's just like,
all sort of combined with each
other, into like a whole...
And then you get for a lot of women,
you get past the first three
months or for six months
or whatever and things start to kind of,
they're still difficult
and you're not getting,
still not getting sleep, but
it starts to kind of settle in.
But I just think we've got to
do a different, a better job,
helping women prepare for
motherhood in a very realistic way
so that things like Angelina
where, you don't get,
feel like you get hit by a two
by four, when a baby comes,
you actually are prepared to say, "Okay,
this is gonna be the hardest thing
you've ever done in your life.
And it's gonna start second one,
when that baby comes,
- Yes!
- in the hospital, when
that baby's on your chest.
- You're like, Whoa! Okay!
- Yeah.
- I mean, you need a plan, absolutely.
- (laughing) Exactly.
- Yeah.
- I think that's so important
that you're verbalizing,
vocalizing that too so
people aren't surprised,
even though I'm sure,
I mean, there's no way
and obviously I'm not speaking
- Right!
- from experience,
- There's no way.
- no way to prepare completely
- 100%.
- But at least they have, the expectation
that you won't be able
to prepare completely.
- Yeah.
- And that
there are somethings that
you can do to set yourself up
for some level of success.
And for me, had I known the information,
I would have planned differently.
I would have hired a
postpartum doula, right.
I would've, I would have
made sure that my husband,
banked vacation days so that
he stayed home, longer with me.
Honestly, I would have taken a second job,
to pay for childcare because
that's what, I needed relief.
So going in knowing what you can handle
and what resources you can call on,
whatever it takes, you will,
you can at least engage the plan
so that you're not so overwhelmed.
And so disengaged from reality.
- It's also like, I mean,
this is where we look at the U.S
and compare ourselves to
other countries, right?
In other countries, you do have midwives
and why don't we have
a whole program where
everyone irrespective
of income or anything
can access a doula during
pregnancy and childbirth
and even postpartum,
why don't we have the resources
in this country to pay for
that and make that available
to any woman that may need it?
Why don't we have paid
family leave in this country,
which is pretty standard
in other countries, right?
Why don't we provide,
nursing and home visit visitation the way,
it exists in other countries?
Why don't we have universal coverage,
so if women are experiencing,
mental health challenges,
they have the resources, I mean like,
there are so many levels of
where we have under-invested
in our human capital, that
show up in all of the things
that Angelina talks about in
her own story that we see in
the statistics around
maternal and infant health.
And frankly, I'm not
saying writing a check
and putting more money in these
things actually eliminates
the problem because then
we have the other issue,
especially as it relates
to black and brown women,
where just the basic effects
of racism and discrimination
impact us on a daily basis.
And that skews the outcomes
as well, disproportionately
relative to women that
look like me and Angelina,
but having said that, a lot of this,
and when you look at ways in
which to address anti-racism
and bias in this country,
policy solutions are at the core
of what we could start to do
to reverse some of the impacts
of what we've been
experiencing over generations
and that we're still living with.
And frankly, to be in
a country, this wealthy
and to not being provided the
basic bare minimum for women
as they're bringing a
new life in the world,
is just simply unacceptable.
I mean, it does...
And it's why I think both of
us are so passionate around,
like we can't live in
this world and society
and tolerate this
and we shouldn't tolerate
for any like the term.
- Yeah, very well said.
And I think it's the support,
the support isn't there, I
think that's what Angelina
was referring to and what,
- Yeah exactly and-
you're articulate as well, just,
it's so critical, but still lacking.
- We need the policy support.
That's a huge component
of the work I do also,
is like, moms in California,
I worked on legislation there
to help with expanding screenings
and also training physicians,
because as Stacey mentioned, doctors,
and labor and delivery
nurses and folks in L and D,
just in general, may not know,
how to implement these
trainings or these screenings.
So there needs to be resources
and time that's invested
to make sure that they're
able to now do this work.
And also when red flags are raised,
where do we send these moms?
I was reaching out to my OBGYN at
two weeks after my eight week checkup.
Like, "Hey, I need more
resources. I need help.
I need medication. I need a therapist."
And she was just kind of
like a deer in headlights.
- Oh boy.
- Yeah.
And then she prescribed
the medication to me,
but never followed up.
So, there's more work to be done,
especially on the policy level.
So that's a part of the reason why I did
the post-partum revolution trip,
was so that we could advocate
for the same, for moms
to have the same exact
treatment in California,
all over the country.
There's no reason why moms in
North Dakota or in Tennessee
where the reproductive
rights are in jeopardy
and are constantly up for
debate and on the ballot box,
but there's no reinforcement
or there's no help once
the babies are here for mom.
- Yeah.
It's one of the big reasons
why one of the things
that we advocate for,
and we're pushing for the
federal level is mom the bus,
which is a whole bunch
of legislative actions
that would address all these things
from maternal mental health
to, all the issues of
reshaping the perinatal workforce.
So we can have more doulas and midwives
and a whole range of other other aspects.
The other thing that March
of Dimes we've done is like
introduce a lot of programs to
provide additional levels of
support, so for example, we,
and we even transferred
to a virtual program
around supportive pregnancy care,
really group prenatal care,
which really allows women to
go through their prenatal care,
obviously checking in
with their physician,
but also checking in with other moms
that are pregnant along with them.
So that you can have an honest
conversation with other women
that might experiencing
some of the same things.
And then continuing that
kind of group care into
the postpartum phase.
Because just when, I mean,
when the baby comes is just
the beginning of your problems, right?
It's like now, you have a
whole set of other issues
to deal with and you
still need that support,
postpartum as well and the
last thing I have to say too,
is going back to this issue
of how the healthcare system
needs to acknowledge the unique challenges
that black and brown women
face and how we know that
the healthcare system
does not listen to us
and respond to us in
the ways that we need.
We introduced an implicit
bias training program
for healthcare professionals
about two years ago,
we've trained 15,000
healthcare professionals
to recognize their implicit bias.
And now we have a new
component which starts
to go through different scenarios,
so you can play out
what scenarios look like
to see where your implicit
bias actually does show up
in your day to day interactions
with your patients.
So, and not just doctors and nurses,
it's really even like the front
desk receptionist who like
give you a side eye when you
show your Medicaid card. Right.
Which is like all of a sudden
now I don't wanna come back
to this clinic because I don't
feel, I don't feel valued.
I don't, I feel like I
feel diminished, right.
And that happens far too often.
And so there all these things we need,
but we just have to do this at scale.
If we're gonna see these
kinds of outcomes improve in
our lifetime.
- Yeah wow.
That's really encouraging
to hear all the steps
that you all have taken across the board,
because it's a huge undertaking.
I mean, you're dealing with
a system that's already
at so many levels,
even as you mentioned from
receptionist all the way up,
there's going to be so
many biases along the way.
And each step along the way,
it's gonna have an impact so.
- Yes.
- Even as I know,
the time is going fast, which
is unfortunate in a sense,
but I did wanna kind of
tie it back to this idea of
the strong black woman,
cause you've talked about,
the things that you've
done on the policy side
and things like that, but
I'm also curious just how,
as you're working in different communities
and in communities of
color, in particular,
how people are embracing of this,
this need for support along the way,
or is there still this tension of,
"Well as strong black women,
we don't need to tap into this."
I'm just curious how that,
how that conversation going.
I'm gonna go to Angelina first,
since I see you smiling as
I'm making those comments.
- Well, Stacey has seen my comedy special
that we are touring
around the country with.
I have a whole section, that addresses
the strong black woman,
(all laughing)
because that myth, we've
gotta flip that on its head.
Strength is asking for help.
Strength is saving the money,
so that you can pay the help, guilt-free,
strength is employing people
to make your life easier.
Strength is enjoying
luxury as black women.
We are because we don't have a history,
of indulging in these kinds of things,
we don't have, when we
are suddenly able to,
we kind of had this guilt or
there's shame and judgment
from family, from friends.
There's a whole thing behind it.
But I always tell people,
strength is really, truly in asking
and allowing people to help you.
My problem was was that I
didn't know what to ask for,
to be helped, and that's
where the preparation for me
would have come in, had
I known what to expect,
I would have been prepared
with what to ask for,
but then also allowing people to help you.
I allowed my therapist to
help me. That was her job.
I allowed my mom to help me,
but I didn't allow my cousins
and my other supportive
family members to help,
until I was in crisis.
And that's what I know,
moving forward that
I tell black women and
mothers, mothers in general,
we feel like we should
be able to do it all.
Carry a baby in the
front, one in the back,
push one in the stroller,
answer, work emails.
On a call, on a Zoom, all at the same....
Mama, we ain't got to do all that.
No, ma'am no, ma'am no ma'am.
We need to have a seat.
But the strong black woman,
the strong black woman asks for help.
So sisters let's start asking for help
and receiving the help.
- Yes.
- That's so good.
- There's a question
black women have been,
have had to be incredibly resilient over
many, many generations.
And it's funny because I go back to
the book about leaning in,
remember Sheryl Sandberg.
And I remember thinking how absurd,
the idea that have the choice to lean
and should I lean in or not?
It's like, "Well,
black women haven't actually
had that choice." Right?
(all laughing)
- True.
- Like we only have a
choice, but the lean in like,
like our families are depending on us.
It's like, the world falls
apart, iff we fall apart,
like it's actually,
that's how it is. Right.
And so I think we have to, I
think we can be both proud of,
that we have proven time and time again,
that we are always ready and willing
to rise to the challenge
and to do what is necessary.
But we have to also acknowledge
that that has traditionally
come at an extraordinary
cost to our health
and to our both mental
health and physical health.
There was research done on, on weathering,
the idea of weathering,
which is kind of how our
health deteriorates over time,
because of just the lived
experience of being a black woman
in this country.
And that weathering then
has an impact on our birth,
on birth outcomes, around babies,
but that stress and
anxiety layered on layered,
year after year, generation
after generation,
actually deteriorates our
lives and our physical health.
And that is not okay.
It is not okay for us to live in
a way where we're
constantly on adrenaline,
constantly on fight or flight,
because that eventually wears
us down to the point where we
see all these chronic health conditions.
I mean, I've told this story
long, have many stories.
Angela has heard me say this
about my own experience of
growing up with my dad,
who was a physician
and him having all these
patients that have stress
and anxiety, but what they
also had was chronic obesity,
hypertension, diabetes,
but he often mostly diagnosed
them with anxiety first, like,
and this was in the 60, 50, 60, 70s.
Like he, even it and
recognized and although he,
I don't know that there
was as much research out at
that time, but he was
actually documenting,
the connection between stress and anxiety
and this other chronic health conditions.
And I carried that thought,
I have carried that thought
with me my entire life,
until I walked into the
opposites of Marsh labs,
became the President CEO
and started to see the actual research
to the evidence around this.
So here, here we are today at all.
All we got, all we can
do right now is to say,
one, we have got to make sure that women,
especially women of color,
find a place in a space in this country
and I call out the United
States in particular,
although we could say
this is a global thing,
but in this particular country,
we have a unique experience
of having to still address
the legacy and of slavery
that has, and we're still
feeling the effects of that,
today, today, and what we
ought to do in this generation
that we are the leaders of right now,
is to call attention to it
and to try to do as much as
we can to reverse the impact,
so that Ava, who was Angelina's
daughter or my daughters,
Maddie and Savannah,
do not have to continue
to live in a world in which
they are continued to be,
they're subjected to the same level of,
kind of oppressiveness that
so many black and brown women
have to face this country.
There shouldn't, we should,
we have to do everything we can.
Fortunately, we're
standing on the shoulders
of many black women and brown
women who fought very hard.
It is our job to get to you that fight
and to elevate that fight
elevated, do even more.
- It's so important and you're
right in terms of the legacy
and just the need to move things forward.
I mean, it's even encouraging to hear,
encouraging and sobering to
hear the story about your father
as well, documenting
those things at that time,
because as you mentioned that
wasn't highly documented.
I mean, there's more evidence
for that now clearly,
and just the detrimental effects
of racism on mental health
and so many other aspects of our health
and especially for black women.
So I'm deeply appreciative
to what you're both doing
in that way.
And to wrap up,
I just wanted to also just
hear what gives you hope
in this moment with all the challenges
that clearly still need to be addressed
in so many ways around mom
health, mom and baby health,
mom's mental health,
but what gives you hope moving forward?
- Well, I'll start.
It, what gives me hope is
seeing the impact of the work,
seeing the impact of an idea that I had,
or to take a risk and share the fact that
I was admitted to a psychiatric
facility on social media
and to see moms open up to me
and ask me to help them check
into a psychiatric facility
and facilitate that.
That gives me hope.
- Wow.
- It gives me hope, to
see my daughter Ava,
and to see that she at six
years old has the language,
not quite the understanding just yet,
but she knows the language
of the postpartum revolution,
postpartum depression, helping
moms, helping families,
helping babies, that gives me hope.
There's still a lot more work to do,
on the postpartum revolution road trip.
I recently met with Congresswoman
Lisa Blunt Rochester,
who is she's working on
the mom the bus and she is-
- She's awesome.
(all laughing)
- A dynamite woman like Stacey, we,
I had an immediate connection with.
I also had a very great
policy meeting with
Congresswoman Yvette Clark on the hill.
And both women are super
supportive of my mission
and my goal to help formulate legislation,
to support new moms and to work with
those of us who worked on
the bill in California,
the bills on California to
make federal legislation.
That gives me hope.
The fact that these women
are willing to meet with me,
an average woman who as Hollywood says,
"No one knows who you are,"
but these women took the time
to hear me and to meet with me
and their policy directors so
that we can help moms who were
in similar situations,
but also helped moms
avoid similar situations.
That gives me hope.
- Yeah.
I think what gives me
hope is just the momentum.
Again, just seeing how
we're having different
kinds of conversations, where,
we weren't having these
conversations before,
I can see minds being open to
really understanding these issues.
I can see people not being
so quick to diminish.
If a woman has a problem
with her pregnancy,
it must be her fault.
It's not her fault. Right.
And people are starting
to say, wait a minute,
maybe there's something more
systemically wrong here.
And that's where in Washington, I mean,
that's in both sides of the Aisle.
I see what Republicans, I mean,
when I see Republican members of Congress,
who are like moved, literally
authentically moved to tears,
when they hear a story
like from Charles Johnson,
about losing his wife, Kira,
hours after their second child was born.
I mean, these are human issues.
And we're living in a time when
there's a lot that doesn't make sense.
And there's a lot of
craziness that goes on.
And there's a lot of things
that people don't believe.
A lot of facts, people just
don't aren't willing accept.
And a lot of people that other
people are willing to dismiss
as if their concerns
or issues don't matter.
And what I'm finding is that
at least on the issue of
mom and baby health,
there is the ability to
find some common ground.
We were at an event last
week with two Republican
members of Congress and
two democratic members.
And one of them said,
"I love coming to a March of Dimes event
because I think this
is the one place where,
Republicans and Democrats can agree."
And they weren't talking
about just March of Dimes,
they were really talking
about the bigger issues
that we're working on,
but that is encouraging
and inspiring to me.
So I think we just gotta keep
that momentum going, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So yeah.
- So again,
I'm deeply appreciated both of you
for the work that you're doing,
also for both of you taking
time to come on this podcast.
I know this is gonna be
something that our listeners are
gonna really resonate with.
Any places
they should go to find out.
- Well thank you
for doing this too,
you're doing a great job.
We appreciate that (laughing).
- Oh thank you.
- It gives hope that you as a black man,
are giving the sisters, the space ha ha.
- Of course, it's the east I can do.
- Not only the space, but the
awareness of your audience
to value what, to value these issues.
I'm just like, "Come on. That
gives me hope, black man.
Come on now."
- It's the least I can do.
- And here it says a Yale
professor and researcher,
a man of faith, and a sports
and hip hop fan is our host.
How about that?
- How about that?
(all laughing)
A balance.
- Bringing it full circle.
- Yes.
- I'm deeply appreciative.
And again, just to see what
you all do as black women.
So encouraging the least
I can do to amplify it
because your voices are being heard,
and need to be heard more.
So I'm playing my part. I'm in
the background this time so,
deeply appreciate both of you.
- Aw! Thank so much.
- Thanks so much for being here.
Check out things at March of
Dimes, angelinaspicer.com,
more information, postpartum revolution,
definitely important work
and appreciate what you're both doing.
Thanks so much.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)